welcome to Hannity buckle up subpoenas
threats of contempt calls for
impeachment of pretty much everyone and
oh yeah
obsessive hysteria over decades-old tax
documents that reveal nothing new and
absolutely nothing illegal and the
media's going nuts again oh that's right
because Muller didn't come out the way
they want let's move on to the next
conspiracy theories and speaking of
which maybe Hillary Clinton colluded
with China to release them because she
said China hope you're listening release
the tax returns and there they are in
the New York Times I know the facts are
hard things for some people in the left
and the medium mob to understand not all
Trump still a billionaire yeah he's
still president we all knew that what
happened is in New Jersey and the casino
business yeah it kind of went south
businesses fail everyday the Trump
Organization is still an overwhelming
American success story but this kind of
vitriol just represents what the
Democratic Party's become weak now tax
you know we're gonna get that for the
next two years we need a special council
Muller we need tax experts you know if
this is a political cabal filled with
sore losers that are now bordering on
rage psychosis akin to that couldn't
accept the results of the 2016 election
now refusing to accept the results of
Muller's investigation and now more on
Hinz than ever
so tonight after more than being
cooperative an abroad 22 month
witch-hunt
president is rightly saying enough is
enough and he's putting his foot down
remember he didn't say or use executive
privilege one time he lied everybody in
the White House to talk to the special
counsel one point five million documents
this week the White House did order
finally fighting back former counsel
dumb again with a not to comply order as
it relates to the congressional subpoena
after all it was already interviewed by
robert muller for a whopping 30 hours
the guy's talked out is not enough to
say and meanwhile under threat of
contempt of Congress
the Attorney General bar he's refusing
to release the full unredacted version
of the Muller report to congressional
Democrats because he's actually
following the law and because the law
was passed by Democrats bar by the way
was not required to release one single
letter no word no phrase nothing of the
Muller report and the only redactions to
the full report include Oh grand jury
information language pertaining to
ongoing cases investigatory sources and
methods can't let that out anyway and
according to press secretary Sarah
Sanders the White House might order the
DOJ to block Robert Muller from
testifying on the hill which kind of
disappoints me I got a lot of questions
for Muller why did he appoint Andrew
Weissman and a band of Democrats and
let's see people that withheld
exculpatory evidence in the past and
people that represented Hillary Clinton
nobody that donated a Republicans I like
a few of those questions
why did Robert Muller not touch Hillary
Clinton's bought and paid for dirty
Russian dossier I know he was busy he
was looking into fair evaluations the
bad loan applications incomplete tax
returns taxi medallions sure he's too
busy to investigate Hillary's bought and
paid for Russian lies and propaganda to
impact the 2016 election which was part
of the Mandate of what he was supposed
to be doing not taxi medallions of
fairer violations what's this should we
take the president's tweet from this
past weekend as in order to build bar to
not allow robert muller to testify I
think that's a determination to be made
at this point I think that's the
president that's the president's feeling
on the matter and the reason is because
we consider this as a case closed as a
finished process and I again I think
that most Americans think that this is
finished
well most Americans do Sanders is right
it's over it's done from now on it's
only noise two and a half years
Democrats media mob the self-obsessed
super Patriots like James Comey in the
deep state trying to rip this country
apart over
a hoax a conspiracy theory with no
evidence and only anonymous sources even
Senate Majority Leader McConnell put it
this way they were hoping for a national
crisis for political gain
that's so patriotic of them isn't it
take a look it's been two weeks since
Attorney General William bar made the
450 page report public this
investigation went on for two years it's
finally over they told everyone there'd
been a conspiracy between Russia and the
Trump campaign yet on this central
question the special counsels finding is
clear case closed
case closed
now the Senators laying out facts
Democrats could not be more detached
from truth reality well let's look at
speech speaker Pelosi she's not really
speaker she speaker name only it's a
it's speaker Acacio Cortez and then
speaker and name only Pelosi take a look
when the floor of the Senate Senator
McConnell is reported to be saying does
it matter to hear from mother case
closed
case closed no think so I don't think so
just as a matter of observation that's
just not a fact the case is not closed
she may want to check in with Speaker
Cascio Cortez because the case is closed
Pelosi went on to the Clare that
President Trump is goading her into
impeachment that's what he's doing you
figured it out I felt the conspiracy
theory just when you think they're
double conspiracy theories and lying is
pull it out of thin air these people are
amazing they should write movies take a
look Trump is coding us to impeach him
that's what he's doing every single day
he's just like taunting taunting
taunting because he knows that it would
be very divisive in the country but he
doesn't really care just wants to
solidify
his face now for Pelosi and her
Democratic colleagues and the media mob
oh it's not about in any way talking
about or legislating or improving the
lives of you we the American people
bettering the economy making the world a
better place more safe more secure more
prosperous
it's always about scoring cheap
political points with their radical base
well let's look at a new poll 57% of
Democrats believe President Trump is
guilty of treason well they've been lied
to every second every minute every hour
of every day on every news channel
except primetime here so you know what
do you expect of course they're gonna
believe that lie according to multiple
surveys vast majority these Democrats
are total of Americans though they're
against impeachment without a doubt the
far-left socialist extreme democratic
socialist party they are out of touch
with truth and reality and can no longer
accept basic fundamental truths same
reason why so many trumpeters are
refusing to admit a simple disturbing
truth as well
the Trump campaign was spied on it
happened and tonight as Byron you're
pointed out not a question of whether
spying took place question is how much
spying and by how many people now even
former National Intelligence clapper but
grudgingly admits this simple truth
looks like spying to be well it was
spying take a look there are protocols
and standard standards for using agent
and I'm sure that's the case here so
you're saying this was not done lightly
well no then it's never done lightly was
it sure was it spying well yeah I I
guess it missed it meets definitely
dictionary definition of spy of
surveillance or spying mmm-hmm
yeah when our federal government send in
sends in undercover agents oh like a hot
blonde bombshell that's really
flirtatious and makes herself available
to George papadopolis for the purpose of
extracting information out of him yeah
that's cool
spying when our own FBI uses a series of
secret informants to set up meetings and
then surveil Trump campaign aides and
trap them into saying things that they
can't say because they don't know that
would be spying and when Carter page
he's gonna join us in a moment had his
calls and emails tapped by our own
federal government after they committed
a massive Pfizer fraud with the bulk of
information the application being
Hilary's Russian dossier that would be
spying too and what's worse the basis
for that spying was Hillary and her
dirty Russian dossier document Comey and
others signed off on you know at the top
of a FISA warrant I just learned this
today it says verified hmm who's never
verified its unverifiable this document
totally unverified we now know filled
with Russian lies New York Times even
suggesting all of it paid for by Hillary
may have all been Russian disinformation
from the get-go and thanks to a brand
new breaking report from the hills John
Solomon we now have one more piece of
damning evidence that the Obama
administration knew that the dossier was
a fraudulent political hack job well
before Comey used it and they used it
for the basis of the FISA application
and according to John Solomon 10 days
before that first FISA requests in
October 2016 the author of that dossier
Christopher Steele confessed to Obama's
Deputy Assistant Secretary of State
quote his research was political and
facing an election day deadline State
Department memorialized this
conversation in a written statement
which was subsequently hidden from
congressman Devin Nunez during the
course of his entire house Intel
investigation the shocking revelation is
now shining light tonight on a series of
texts between FBI officials page and
struck that referenced an effort to
speed up the completion of the FISA
requests likely we know used against
Carter page we're gonna get back to my
monologue on this and hear from Carter
page in a minute but first